Where are we?
So we're on page 669, and we're
going to start on test
number five, section seven.
Problem number one-- if k is a
positive integer divisible by
3, and if k is less than 60,
what is the greatest possible
value of k?
So it's a positive integer
greater than-- it's positive,
so it's greater than 0.
It's divisible by 3, and
it's less than 60.
k is less than 60.
60 is divisible by 3, right?
3 times 20 is 60.
So if I subtract 3 from
60, that will also be
divisible by 60.
So k is equal to 57.
Right? k can't be 60 because
it's less than 60.
And then the next
one down is 57.
And if you don't believe that
3 is divisible into 57-- 3
goes into 57-- 1, 1 times 3,
27-- goes into it 19 times.
There you go.
So the choice is C, 57.
And if you haven't learned this
already, the easiest way
to figure out if the
number's divisible
by 57, add the digits.
So 5 plus 7 is 12,
1 plus 2 is 3.
So if when you add the digits,
the sum you get is divisible
by 3, then the original number
is also divisible by 3.
So you could actually have gone
down the choices, but you
don't want to waste too much
time on the first problem.
Problem two-- the letter H is
symmetric with respect to two
different lines, as shown
in the dotted line
in the figure above.
Which of the following is
symmetric with respect to at
least two different lines?
So when they talk about H,
they're saying-- if I draw an
H, they draw this line
of symmetry here.
And that means if I were to flip
H over this way, I get
the same thing.
If I were to flip it over this
line, I get the same thing.
It's like a mirror image
on either side.
Right?
This green line is a mirror
image of this purple line.
And the other way is true too.
If I have H, this mauve part
is the mirror image of this
brown part along the
horizontal axis.
If I were to draw a--
if this was the axis
of the mirror image.
So which of the other
letters has it?
So it should be a letter that
looks the same-- that could be
kind of folded in half either
vertically or horizontally.
And if we look at all
the choices, X is
definitely the answer.
Because if you have an X, and if
you have a vertical line of
symmetry, notice that the
left-hand side is the mirror
image of the right-hand side.
Or you could flip
it over, right?
They look the same.
It almost looks like a
reflection of the other side.
Similarly, if you took
it the other way.
Also you could flip it up and
down, and they also have the
mirror image.
None of the other letters
have that property.
Next problem.
Problem number three.
Bobby receives $2.00 for each
chore he does during the week,
plus a weekly allowance
of $10.00.
If Bobby receives no other
money, which of the following
expressions represents the
total dollar amount Bobby
receives per week in which
he does n chores?
So if he does n chores, how much
money is he going to get
just from doing chores?
He does n chores, and how much
does he get per chore?
Well, he gets $2.00.
Times 2.
So this is how much he gets
just from doing chores,
2n, or n times 2.
And then how much is he
going to get even
if he does 0 chores?
He gets a $10.00 allowance no
matter what, far more than I
ever got as a child.
So what is the formula?
It's 2n plus 10, is the amount
of money he gets.
And that is choice D.
Right?
n is the number of chores, he
gets $2.00 per chore, and he
gets $10.00 no matter what,
even if n is 0, even if he
does no chores.
Next problem, four.
The smallest squares in figure
A and figure B are
all equal in size.
If the area in A is 26 square
centimeters, what is the area
of figure B?
So let's see if I can
draw these figures.
So I'll use the line tool, so a
looks like-- let's see, you
have a line there.
So let me draw a rectangle.
So the rectangle looks
like that.
Close enough.
And then there's another
rectangle that's like this.
Another rectangle like this--
the drawing is the hardest
part, my shaky hands.
OK, almost there.
I think you get the point,
I try my best.
Have to give me credit.
OK, so that's figure A, and then
figure B looks like this.
Horizontal line, and then a
vertical line like that.
And then, let's see,
it has that.
Connect these two.
And then-- oh boy,
this is tiring.
I have a line like that.
And then it gets split roughly
in half over there.
And then this connects
like that.
That connects like that.
And then I have a
line like that.
So what they're telling us is in
figure A-- whoops, I don't
want to do that, edit undo--
what they're saying is figure
A, each of these squares are the
same size as each of these
squares in figure B.
And they also tell us that
figure A is 26 square
centimeters.
So the area is 26 centimeters
squared.
So we want to figure
out the area of B.
We have to just figure out,
how big is each of these
little tiles?
Right?
So how many tiles are in a?
Let's count them.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
13 tiles.
And they're 26 centimeters
cubed total, right?
So if 13 times the area of
a tile is equal to 26
centimeters, a tile-- divide
both sides by 13-- is 2
centimeters squared, right?
Each tile is 2 centimeters
squared.
And how many tiles
does B have?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
It has 8.
So its area is 8 times the
number of tiles-- or the area
of the tiles.
And we know what the area of
the tiles are-- it's 2,
because it's the same as A.
So area is equal to 8 times
2, which is equal to 16
centimeters squared,
which is choice C.
Next problem.
More drawing for Sal.
Oh boy, it's the drawing
that really tires me.
OK.
And I have to draw it pretty
accurately, because
otherwise-- this is all
about reading a graph.
All right, so let me draw.
Let me make the first one-- so
Albert goes to like 300.
This is 300.
And then it's 150, which is
roughly half of that.
And then the next guy is
like a little over 200,
so it's like 2/3.
I'm just trying my best,
trying my best.
Then the next guy, I guess
at like 250, here.
And then the last guy-- I'm
drawing the white boxes, this
is pretty much the
same number.
Like that.
And then let me draw the other
one in here, so the
other guy is 150.
This guy gets to 250.
Which I said was roughly
the same amount as
these guys over here.
Next guy looks about the same.
250, that's about that.
And this guy is like that.
All the work I'm doing now is
just to redraw what you
already have. Then this guy is
like 350, 300 or something.
If I were to draw-- let
me mark it off.
So this is 300, this is 150--
see those guys that are a
little bit under 200.
So this is like 200,
this is 250.
They're asking us, according
to the graph above, which
salesperson had the greatest
increase in the number of
units sold from 1988 to 1999?
So the 1988 ones are
the blue ones, and
1999 are the red ones.
So you're essentially saying,
who had the greatest increase
going from the blue
to the red, right?
And this is Albert, this is
Goldberg, Patel-- that's nice,
they included an Indian guy.
Smith, Wang.
I look forward to when
they have a Khan on
the SAT, but anyway.
So who increased the most going
from the blue year,
1998, to 1999.
This guy clearly decreased,
right?
He went from 300 to 150,
so it's not him.
This guy decreased, he went
from something larger to
something smaller,
so it's not him.
So who had the largest
increase?
Well, you could eyeball
it, right?
Where are the increases?
This guy increased this much,
compared to a small increase
here, and a small
increase here.
So the answer is G, or Goldberg,
which is choice B.
See you in the next video.